- What's up, Kicks family? It's your boy Meech
back here again with our new debate show
"Sneaker Swap," where we argue a lot.
You know I've got the usual guys with me:
CJ, Christian, Jeff.
Gentlemen, how are we doing?
- Yo.
- Doin' good.
- Good, man.
- Topic for today:
If you had the Travis Scott Air
Jordan 4, would you trade it
for the Off-White Air Jordan 4?
I wanna hear—
and this is tough.
This is tough.
I wanna hear from my man Jeff first.
Talk to me.
- Oh, man.
I gotta set it up.
All right, cool.
- Start it up.
- So, I've probably been labeled the Travis.
Scott kicks hater for the last
couple of videos, but understand
this is probably pound for pound
my favorite one that he did.
I love the color blue.
I love the colorway.
I'm a wrestling fan.
So you know Cactus Jack is A-1 with
me. And it's just—I'm not a 4s guy,
and those are the type of
4s that make me wanna cop,
like, a million pairs of them.
I like,
I like some of the Off-Whites, but
the 4s, like when I saw the 4s,
the Off-White 4s, I was like, “Yo,
that's something that I would wanna cop.”
But if you're talking about I
had the Travis Scotts already,
there's no way. It's so versatile.
It just looks good.
It doesn’t even look like a 4,
If that makes sense.
It looks like it's its own alternate
reality version of the 4s,
but just like even more fire.
So yeah, I can—there's a, there's
a bunch of other Off-Whites
that I could have other than
those 4s. The Travis 1s aren't
the ones I'm giving up for them.
- OK.
I love that
take, Jeff. Christian,
it's all you.
- See, fellas,
I actually
appreciate this trade for once.
Cuz this is actually the first trade
where I actually have these sneakers.
- Wow!
- Whoa! This is what we doin’?!
- This is a fresh method.
He's doing, he's going method.
- Bro, this is the first shoe
that we've done so far,
the first Sneaker Swap
where I actually have the shoe.
So all that being said, if I
had the Off-White 4s, would I
trade it for the Travis Scotts?
I still am trading for
the Travis Scott 4s.
I'm still doing it.
Don't get it twisted.
I'll be there
just like y'all on Saturday, ready
to catch this L, same time, same
place, everything, whatever, you
know. But, like, no disrespect
to the 4s, Off-White 4s, but the
Travis Scott 4s are just that much better.
Jeff said it. That Houston Oiler
colorway, the suede on the top.
And, like, I know they're not even
talking about it, but, bro, that,
like, Friends and Family colorway,
the purple ones, don't even get
me started.
But, like, a lot of that. And plus,
technically this is his
first collab with Jordan Brand,
you know what I mean?
Like, all respect to the Air Force
1s he did with Nike and all that,
but this is probably his first—
this is his first one
and arguably the one that set
him up for, like, where he is in
the sneaker culture right now.
And I honestly think it’s his
best shoe with, like, Jordan Brand,
you know? Like, Travis Scott 4s,
Travis Scott Jordan 1s.
- Wow.
- Not the 1s.
- Maybe it’s a hot take, I don’t know.
- Wow.
- That's a decent take, bro.
That's a decent take.
Cuz those Travis—the 1s
are FIRE fire, but I get it.
I get it.
I get it, yo. I get it.
- First of all, I just want to say bravo
to everyone for not making a single—
we made it four minutes without
making a single Virgil joke into this thing.
- Oh, they're coming.
They're coming.
- Soon, soon.
- I know they’re coming, but I
just wanna acknowledge it.
I wanna, I want it to ramp up. But,
listen, I actually like both sneakers.
All disrespect aside from Virgil.
These are, these are some of my
favorite Off-Whites. On the 4,
I didn't—like, the 4 is, for
me, it’s such an iconic silhouette.
And when the Travises came out, I
was like, “That's the way you do,
that's the way you do a new take on
the 4.” Because that blue is classic.
They did go with everything. But this
Off-White 4, the cream colorway, like,
I don't know if you guys are like
gumsole fanatics like me. This is
like if the gumsole was the whole
shoe. But all that being said, so I pick
Off-White 4s, but
I don't know if
Virgil will ever see this.
The deconstructed look,
this is your last one, Virgil.
Like, it's run dry.
Like, go out on a high note.
It's these, it's the Off-White 4s.
He did a good job on these. That
cream colorway goes with everything.
But,
I don't know.
You gotta, you gotta
change it up a little bit, Virgil.
- CJ,
I need you to come home.
This is his best Off-White shoe,
you said?
- You heard it here.
- Shout-out to
another guy on the B/R Kicks team who gave
me the other—again, I have hot takes on
the Off-White line, but the Hyperdunks
are the only other Off-Whites I like.
- Hmm.
- OK.
- With the strap, I just—it seems
like there are real work done,
a real Virgil take on
these, on these silhouettes.
And yeah, I think that it's
one of the best I've seen.
- Well, I just want to get to a point
where I could make something and
write the actual name of what it is—
- Right?!
- And get thousands of millions of dollars.
Like, that's a stunt.
Like, joke on him all you want.
But my man literally writes the
color of the sneaker on the sneaker
and sells thousands of dollars.
Like, he's, he's done it.
He's found the loop.
He didn't reinvent the wheel.
He wrote “Wheel” on the wheel
and he makes thousands of dollars.
You can't hate on that.
You can't.
Like I said, I
guess that's fashion, bro.
You guys already know
how I'm rocking big Cactus.
Jack.
Travis is the one.
Everything,
every sneaker that he's
touched is a banger.
It's a hit. Just like his tracks,
his sneakers are hits. CJ,
I think you made a great point.
Virgil did a really good job.
The cream colorway’s
good.
But I feel like I've seen this somewhere.
I'm not gonna say, I'm not gonna
name names, but I've seen this somewhere.
I think Travis always brings
a unique vision for his shoes.
It's always something we've never
seen. Like you're saying: the blue
on the 4, the reverse swoosh
on the 1, the stash on the 6s.
Travis is just doing
it a little differently.
I think he's thinking on a
higher plane than Virgil, right?
- Whoa.
- A higher plane?
- I didn't say that.
I agree with you.
- I think he's thinking on a higher
plane than Virgil right now.
100 percent.
- Wait, Meech, so you're telling me you
would take Travis’, like, what,
top three, top five shoes over
Virgil's top three, top five?
- Yes.
Yes.
I'm taking—
all right.
- What’s Virgil’s top three?
- Hold on.
- Virgil’s top three?
- Exactly. Exactly.
We're gonna say the Presto.
- I think Prestos,
Chicagos, Chicago 1s.
- Serenas,
the Air Maxes.
Let's not include, let’s not include
the Jordans though.
- It’s up there.
We can't include the Jordans.
This has to be a Nike Jordan thing.
- Nah. Nah, nah, nah.
Include all of it, boy.
- OK, Prestos.
Chicago 1s.
And what's the last one?
- Oh, I like those 5s a little bit.
The recent ones.
- I would say his
first Air Force 1 was heat.
- OK
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- But how—it's really hard to
mess up an Air Force 1, even though
Nike has been doing that.
- Add a random air bubble.
- But, and again, inspired by Virgil
I feel like, the deconstructed look, but
I will say he did it perfectly. That and
the Air Max 1. I feel like the black
Air Max 1s were pretty dope.
- But I mean, yeah, I'm definitely taking
Travis's top three over Virgil’s
top three.
100 percent.
Do you see, do you see the hat?
Cuz, like, cause we're gonna, we’re
gonna do the 4s, right?
- Yeah.
- We'll do the blue colorway.
- Definitely gonna do the 1s.
I feel like 1s and the Chicagos,
they, they balance out. They balance
out. They cancel out.
- OK. Yeah,
I'll give you that.
- OK.
- What about those yellow suede
6s that haven't been released?
- I don't know if we could do that
yet since it's not released.
- Not out, yeah.
Can’t do it. It’s gotta be released.
- Those are crazy.
Those would win everything right now.
- OK, are the
4s and the Prestos a wash?
- I don't know, bro.
- That’s tough.
- I don't know.
I think I'm taking the 4s
over the Prestos.
- I'm taking
the 4s over the Prestos.
- Yeah.
I'm not a Prestos guy, so yeah,
the 4s.
- Yeah, I was gonna
say the same thing.
Like, I'm not a Prestos, so it may
not be fair, but it's—I don't
see a lot of things beating those 4s, bro.
- Yeah.
- But, like, we don't have to
necessarily talk about the blue colorway.
There's also the purple.
- I mean, if we're gonna talk about
something to beat those Travis 4s,
we could talk about the Doernbechers.
Those Superman Doernbechers.
- Yeah, those are sick.
- And, and let’s not
get it twisted. Them kids
are better designers than some of these
other designers that get paid thousands
of dollars. Them kids have put out heat.
- Yes.
- And I hope that they raise all the
money that they can for that hospital.
They get over all their ailments,
and they're able to heal, and they
get into some type of design
something, some type of arts. Because
Jordan Brand needs to hire them.
- Who is the most influential person
on Jordan Brand's roster?
- Design or—
- Michael Jordan.
- You're saying rappers, athletes, all of them?
- Person.
- Yeah, Michael Jordan.
- Christian, I can't—I don't know who could beat him.
- Michael. Travis. Scott.
- Listen, Travis did—Travis in
the last few years, probably
yeah.
He revived the brand, for sure.
- Yes. Yes.
- For sure.
Cuz, I mean, I would say, I mean,
Jordan Brand, good year for them because
Travis being involved obviously,
“The Last Dance.” Like, people have
seen the Jordan highlights, that’s
helped. I've seen general release
Jordan 1s now cost 800 bucks.
I just went to try and go
get the Jordan 1 Storm Blues.
They're 800 right now.
Those were, like, hitting Twitter
deal accounts back in the day.
And now I'm like, “I'm not paying resale for a
white and blue colorway of the Jordan 1s.”
But I would say, yeah, Travis is influential,
and he saved that brand a little bit.
- Who's more important to the
brand, Travis or Michael Jordan?
- Come on.
- In terms of what?
- In terms of moving shoes,
who's more important?
I personally think that if Michael left
the brand today, those shoes are still
gonna move. Those shoes still—
- But if he left the brand,
is he taking Jordan Brand with it?
- He can’t!
- Let say he left,
and Jordan Brand would
still be Jordan Brand.
- Yes.
- They still could put out
whatever colorways or whatever.
- Mhmm.
- I think you still, I think you can't
take away the fact that he elevated
the entire sneaker game, because
if he wasn't Michael Jordan, those
sneakers wouldn't move to begin with.
- OK.
- And then if we talk about,
yes,
we'll have to put Team
Jordan over here for a second,
right?
If we talk about the ones that
move on average, what Travis—what's
Travis’ clip? Once every 18 months
or something? Like, once every 12
months? He puts out one yearly.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- OK,
so in one year, he has one line, but
Jordan Brand may drop four or five
new colorways, retro colorways
that are gonna move.
So if we're talking about actual—
if we're talking about money, then
Jordan by default is more important.
If we're talking about design and fresh
takes, then I would say Travis, because
they're not, they're not doing what
Travis is doing in terms of innovation
to the actual colorways.
- I guess if you’re
talking right now, like where the
energy is, like—I’ll take it a step further.
Honestly, I think rappers in
general are the most important
thing to the sneaker game, period.
Like, if you're just thinking of
Travis, you have Drake, you have
Kendrick Lamar, you have—
- Kanye.
- Kanye, exactly. Pharrell.
Even like, I didn't even know who
G-Dragon was, but like—
- A$AP.
- Yeah, A$AP too, you know what I'm saying?
But, like, they're the most
important thing to the sneaker game.
They're pushing the energy in general.
So, that's where it is.
- I will say though, guys: Do
not cross Michael Jordan. We
saw 10 hours of reasons
why not.
So I'm saying it comes
down to if Travis left
the brand,
Jordan has a bag full of tricks.
It is—
like, you can go to a Supreme, you can
go to another artist. Like,
that's the scary—like, Jordan Brand,
whoever is behind it, whether it's Jordan
himself, like, they will figure out
the new Travis Scott, unfortunately.
- Mhmm.
- But that's what, that's why
all respect to Kanye cuz he
challenged Nike and was like, “It's me.
This is, it's all on me.”
And so he went to Adidas, and he did
his own thing and look at where we are
now, you know?
- Jordan Brand needs a
lot of these collaborations to kinda
stay relevant and, like, even going
back to the Off-White 4s in general,
and Jeff, you mentioned the
Doernbecher 4s.
Like, the reason why I think the
Off-White 4s aren't even there—
well, they're there, but, like, not to the
Travis 4s—cuz, like, there's just
better Jordan 4 collabs in general.
Like, I think the KAWS
Jordan 4 is better.
- That’s the best.
- The Levi’s 1 might be better.
Even the Undefeated
4s might be better.
- You know what ones aren't better?
- What?
- The Wahlburgers.
You can keep those, Marky Mark.
We do not need your
fast food collab 4s.
- I mean, I’ll flip ‘em.
- Yeah, he’ll flip ‘em.
He’ll still
sell ‘em to Jimmy.
- Let's throw Eminem in there as well.
- Facts, yeah. Eminem 4.
- No way.
- That’s saying a lot, though.
That is saying a lot because, like,
those Virgil 4s are fire.
- They are.
- So to say that,
it's just showing the quality of the 4s.
The 4s might have some of the
best collabs out of all the Jordans
now that I'm thinking about it.
Like, now that I sit here and think,
like, that's saying a lot. Like,
it's almost like how if you
lost a battle rap to Daylyt when he
went off in his recent battle.
- Right.
- Whatchu gonna say?
You tip your hat. Like,
he went off. Somebody goes off, it's
like, “Oh, I lost to, I lost to a GOAT.
I lost to a legend.”
If Michael Jordan beats me
one-on-one in basketball,
what are y'all really gonna say to me?
I don't do this for a living.
If I scored once, that's my championship.
So to measure Virgil's 4s
up against those other 4s,
it's just showing how
important, like Christian is
saying, those collabs are, man.
Cuz you take those away and
it's, you know, how many times
am I gonna buy the Breds?
I might buy them a lot, but still!
How many times can I actually
buy them and I really need them?
- So back to the topic of Virgil,
I wanna bring this together.
I wanna ask the question,
who's done more for their respective
brands, Travis Scott for Jordan
or Virgil for Nike?
- Virgil did more for
his brand in general, just cuz of,
like, taking what he did with Off-White
in general and flipping it with Nike
and Jordan and flipping it to LV.
Like, that's a, that's
a crazy kind of flip.
I don't know how you do that.
So,
I mean, all jokes aside I
guess on Virgil, like,
that's very impressive.
So, Travis is still working on his
collabs. All love to him and his shoes,
but definitely Virgil, I think,
has done more for his brand as a whole.
- I know I picked the Virgils, the
Off-White 4s up top, but I think Travis
has at least had more fun and gave it a
little bit more variety with his
versions, you know? Again, it's
like for every single collab he's done,
he's come up with, like, almost
a premise, you
know? It's, like, upside down swoosh.
It's that little pocket on the 6s.
Like, I appreciate that creativity. Now,
again, Virgil,
he has really unlocked that
deconstructed look, but
I haven't seen much modifying that
or toying with it as it evolves.
- Right.
- So I would have to go Travis
in terms of, like, evolved and,
like, really done something with
his sort of opportunity.
- I don't know if the average sneaker fan
knew or sneakerhead knew who Virgil was,
as opposed to knowing who Travis was.
So Virgil coming in as
a designer—hip-hop
and sneaker culture
have been inextricably linked. They're
one and the same. They've grown from
the same actual culture of graffiti
and music and art and all of that,
right?
They've grown from the
same foundation.
- Right.
- So
for a rapper to come in and make a
fire collab with a sneaker company,
I'm almost expecting that.
- OK.
- So I don't know if I'm expecting
somebody from the fashion world to make
a sneaker that I would want. Like, that
I think is gonna be fire off top.
Cuz they may go left, and I say, “You
know, that's not how I roll.”
So I think in terms of their own personal
brand, Virgil expanded to a whole ‘nother
part of the culture. But in terms of
what they actually did for
the brands that they created,
I think, I think it
kinda evens out, man.
I think Travis, Travis was
more surgical with it, where it
was specific sneakers and
he's putting his all into that as
opposed to Virgil having the breadth
of all of the different types.
He didn't just stick with Jordan.
He did Nike too.
- Right.
- So, and he had one style across
all sneakers as opposed to unique
styles across a few sneakers.
- Yeah, that’s true.
- So I think, I think it's kinda—I
think it's personal preference in terms
of what they've done for the brand.
Either way, Nike and Jordan—I
guess we should just say Nike—
just, they've been cakin’, bro.
- So, you know, we were talking about
trading the Travis Scott Air Jordan 4s
for the Off-White Air Jordan 4s.
Can you guys— let's go around and
tell me what is your favorite
Air Jordan 4 collab. I would
say Undefeated.
Like, I don't—I just think Undefeated
does a great job with anything
they touch. Been a big
fan of theirs for a long time.
It goes with everything.
And obviously the 4 is
just a beautiful silhouette.
I would definitely go Undefeated.
- My favorite—
all right, I’m gonna cop out.
My favorite Jordan 4 collab is
either the Travis Scott Jordan
4s or the KAWS Jordan 4.
Those are the two fire
Jordan 4 collabs I’ve ever seen, so.
- Yeah, I gotta go,
I gotta go—
I was gonna say the
Undefeateds. That colorway
is just literally undefeated. But
the KAWS, yeah, the material.
The thing about KAWS collabs
are always that it looks quality.
- Yeah.
- And, like, you got that nice—
what is it,
suede?
And then, like, the little,
like, laser details, almost.
Like, the gray and black ones,
those are—you
can't.
- Yeah.
- If I had to pick two shoes to
have in my collection and
only those, I could
live with the KAWS 4s.
- I think for me, it's
the Doernbecher 4s.
Those are the ones that
I always wanted to have.
I'm the type of person that I
like stories behind the sneakers.
And I like the individuality of the
artists to shine and be exhibited
on the sneaker, and for it to be a
young kid, young kid in a hospital,
that's making these to raise money,
like, you can't beat that.
And also the subtle, the subtle—
and it's really overt too—but
looking at the design, how it's an
all-black with the Superman logo
and then the green kryptonite, like,
surrounding the, surrounding the sneakers.
You see so much through it and,
like I said before, man, these kids,
these kids are designers, all right?
- Yeah.
- Like, their creativity, it feels like
you give them a blank canvas and you're
gonna get an all-time sneaker.
And those are some things
that I would wear proudly just
because of what it represents,
and it's just fire. And I’m, as
y'all can see, I love comics.
You know what I'm saying?
So, why not?
Why not?